esta semana se definieron las
semifinales de la copa libertadores
palmeiras atlético paranaense vélez y
flamengo superaron los cuartos de final
atletico paranaense se medirá frente a
palmeiras el actual bicampeón mientras
que vélez se enfrenta a flamengo las
semifinales se abren el 30 y 31 de
agosto y la vuelta se define el 6 y 7 de
septiembre
adriático y vélez comienzan jugando en
casa para analizar este tema nos
acompaña como siempre estará castro
directora de deportes de caracol radio y
del diario de colombia bienvenidas ahora
siempre un gusto estar con ustedes juan
ahora vamos a empezar hablando de
palmeiras que es el campeón y el
bicampeón que sufrió ante atlético
mineiro para superar los cuartos de
final demostraron jerarquía en penal
dice este equipo en el pasado parecía
que antes a pesar de tener buenos
equipos no se encontraba en copa
libertadores ahora parece que por fin
encontraron un idilio con este torneo
cuando hablamos de un equipo que es
bicampeón de la libertadores hay que
hablar primero de la estructura esto
palmeiras es un equipo bien gestionado
con un patrocinador fuerte y yo creo que
de ahí empieza a encajar todo luego la
llegada de abel ferreira como entrenador
que era una apuesta una apuesta
complicada portugués sin mucha
experiencia en la primera división
apenas algunos partidos en el sporting
braga y en el paok griego es decir que
es este momento en el que todas las
piezas se empiezan a unirse en el tiempo
y con los recursos adecuados yo creo que
hay que hablar de la manera como él
logró convencer a un equipo de jugadores
jóvenes él aprovechó mucho la cantera de
palmeiras y le imprimió ese toque que
hace a los equipos diferentes él tiene
una frase es que los resultados los
resultados e incluso durante el partido
no pueden afectar el rendimiento o los
comportamientos colectivos que han sido
trabajados durante la semana por eso
podemos ver que en los momentos
difíciles suelen sobreponerse e imponer
esas eso ese trabajo que se ha hecho con
el entrenador para lograr los resultados
al final del partido yo creo que es
importante decir que si bien ha sido
cuestionado porque es un equipo en
teoría defensivo es un equipo que no le
interesa ser protagonista con la pelota
tiene esa idea muy clara un equipo muy
ordenado que le gusta explotar los
espacios a la espalda de la defensa
rival y creo que esto ha sido muy
importante y muy bien aprovechado un
equipo con el 80
de rendimiento en copa libertadores yo
creo que indica la manera como esos
conceptos y esta idea del entrenador que
ha logrado encajar muy bien con sus
jugadores pues tiene muchas
probabilidades de llevarse una vez más a
este campeonato y que además han
conseguido retener a la gran parte de
sus estrellas en este equipo vamos a
hablar de los otros tres semifinalistas
flamengo uno de los mejores equipos del
continente dos veces campeón vélez que
ganó la copa en 1994 y tenemos atletico
paranaense que busca el primer título
que podemos decir de los otros
competidores atlético paranaense
empecemos por el último busquen el
primer título con un técnico de
muchísima experiencia contra todo el
distrito escolar y en mayo de este año
un técnico que fue campeón con gremio en
el 95 con palmeras en el 99 y que si
bien digamos que no ha estado en mucho
contacto con el fútbol de digamos con
grandes resultados en los últimos años
yo creo que impone muy bien esa
jerarquía que se necesita cuatro
triunfos y dos de los empates es
su récord en esta copa libertadores el
trabajo sobre lo que ya había construido
el anterior técnico y luego le sumo esa
capacidad de imponer dos jugadores clave
por un lado te hago heleno en la defensa
y david terán en esa construcción del
juego del equipo yo creo que va a ser un
club complicado en esta fase del torneo
nos gusta vélez que tuvo una llave muy
complicada contra talleres sin embargo
el técnico medina yo creo que ha hecho
un trabajo muy interesante él llegó
también en mitad a esta libertadores ya
con el torneo avanzado y logró eliminar
a river plate yo creo que esa es una de
los grandes retos y de los grandes
digamos que reconocimientos que ya puede
ir sumando este equipo en prato como
pivote como 9 de área con jugadores que
llegan por los extremos yo creo que eso
es lo que lo que más podemos destacar
del juego de este equipo y luego está
flamengo un equipo del que se habla
mucho más de sus jugadores que del
entrenador un equipo con un costo de más
de 160 millones de euros para el
continente empieza a marcar una
diferencia
evidentemente jugadores como david luis
filipe luís de arrascaeta
gaby gol es decir estamos hablando de un
equipo muy bien formado y si bien no se
habla mucho de dorival junior yo creo
que el hecho de poder tener todas estas
figuras ahora llegó incluso el chinero
el chileno arturo vidal indica esa
capacidad de tener un equipo ordenado
muy intenso con una propuesta totalmente
diferente es paradójico pero los tres
anteriores equipos de los que hablamos
tienen juegan un 4 3 4 2 3 1 este es el
único equipo que juega con un 4-3-3
donde rescata que es muy protagonista en
esta generación de juego así que yo creo
que dorival júnior también tiene mucho
que ver en este equipo
con mucha intensidad un equipo que
siempre busca ser protagonista en los
partidos y que si busca ser protagonista
con la pelota con la posesión y muy
generador yo creo que veremos unos una
solución al es bastante interesantes del
esta copa libertadores decía arturo
vidal que flamengo puede competir
perfectamente en la champions league el
chileno es ahora como siempre muchas
gracias por este análisis